So niches idea was that human beings,
we're going to have to create their own
values essentially.
Now he understood that we had bodies and
that we had motivations and emotions
like he was a romantic thinker in some
sense,
but way ahead of his time because he
knew that our capacity to think wasn't
some free floating soul,
but was embedded in our physiology,
constrained by our emotion,
shaped by our motivation,
shaped by our body.
He understood that,
but he still believed that the only
possible way out of the problem would be
for human beings themselves to become
something akin to God and to create
their own values.
That was,
that's and he thought that the person he
talked about the person who could create
their own values as the overmanned or
the superman,
and that was one of the parts of
Nietzschean philosophy that the Nazis,
I would say,
took out of context and used to fuel
their superior man ideology.
So we know what happened with that.
That didn't seem to turn out very well.
That's for sure.